young Max one more offense and you'll be
behind bars Flora you're his mother
find him something to do
what are you doing right now
you don't want to know
you are a great mother am I happy
birthday what's that it's yours don't
want to play since one of my guitars I
can't go on like this living in a shoe
box with a kid who hates me can't wait
for the day I don't have to be here
guitar myself that's just tell for me it
takes years of practice commitment are
you really really talk to me about
commitment
[Music]
we're ready to teach you how to shred on
guitar
so you want to learn the guitar this is
a gift you can take your grave what's
your problem I didn't know I had a
problem
we're teaching guitar online love what
are you hoping to get out of this I
thought this guitar might make me some
think I'm cool I'll be back in an hour I
don't care how annoying is he very
annoying
what is that
was that yours
how did you make that it sounded epic
come on girl let's get in trouble
shaking no sir the James Bond from
Dublin
why don't you screw can I try that one
it's too big that's the look
yeah for tortless
she's totally out of my league let's
write a song just to hear your passion
Express Yourself
she hated it yo just get out of my way
gladly
17 with the screaming child I mean up
it's not being my story
but without him we have nothing
how come the way things are never enough
for you
they never were
[Music]
playing the guitar it's so sexy
okay is that why you took it off let's
focus on you
are you coming on to me